hey Bill hey Theo this is Marisa from
Raleigh North Carolina and so bill I
heard you say on I believe it was Joe
Rogan's podcast that you really liked
the film Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
and you've seen it several times and I
know Theo said that he walked out
halfway through it so I was just
wondering maybe if you could talk about
why you loved it so much and feel why
you walked out halfway through it anyway
Gang Gang well this is where Bill and I
don't talk anymore after this no no I
didn't like you didn't like it
I absolutely [ __ ] loved it I heard on
your podcast you said you loved it oh my
god dude it's the best work Leo's I mean
Brad Pitt scored first time you watch it
I was just like I want to be like Brad
Pitt's the guy I want to be yeah and
then the second time I watched it I was
like oh my god I'm just like Leo's
character I have an emotional [ __ ]
mess well I don't know what part you
walked out and I walked out after they
went to that house for the first time
after they met the old guy and we were
in the yard and then his car was had a
flat tire and at that point I was like I
got to get out of here I don't know what
these guys are doing you know I felt
like it was just kind of a waste of I
don't know it just I couldn't get into
it and I didn't know what was going on
and it made me feel uncomfortable I was
like I gotta get out of here because I
started to feel like everybody knows
what's going on and I don't know what's
going on
you know I guess yeah that's that's for
you and the therapist buddy yeah that
house do you at the [ __ ] movies if
you think the whole the whole movie
theater gives a [ __ ] about whether are
you making like audible noises that you
did huh whoa oh that's the only way they
would know [ __ ] man I don't know it's so
[ __ ] up man - yeah you do
yeah you do - I really did it though I
really did it man I'm not gonna sit here
and try to talk you into that
masterpiece
it's one of my might be my favorite
thing after you said that's unbelievable
do you remember that remember that movie
um dream team probably one of the best
movies ever remember Michael Keaton
I love Michael Keaton what was the dream
team will you show the picture I've seen
everything everything from mr. mom
Annette but the thing he did about like
when he was trying to run the American
car making company oh that was a great
one I know you talking about hold that
tiger that
when he says that the light in the
middle no that's Kevin Costner was in
that no that was Tucker with that was
good yeah
how good was that they should remake
that there you go right there
I never saw that one Oh probably the top
20 or 30 films ever I think it's in
color too dream team it's about four
guys that they're a mental health
facility and they finally get tickets to
a baseball game I never saw that one
I've seen most of his films you ever see
founder is that about the dog that dies
no that's about McDonald's oh my god
yeah you saw that right you like that
one no good there you go you didn't walk
out you didn't feel like see that I
understand that's food like this one so
much talking can't handle this was like
that was sift it was subtitles I could
see why you wouldn't [ __ ] enjoy that
wouldn't did it for me bro that founder
was so good I love something that has I
think more of like a like glory member
to movie glory about the slave fight
from nineteen uh no from 1700 wasn't
that a Denzel movie Matthew Broderick
Denzel Washington Wayans yeah so I don't
think feel like slice of life cuz from
whatever that was once upon a time a
Hollywood not a ton of narrative arc
just that's that's slice of life that's
what people are saying that's what
people are saying bill it is slice alike
yeah they're just living ok can we look
up the definition I didn't know what it
yeah we look up slice of life again it
was the Manson murders with a happy
ending that was the backdrop yeah I
liked uh oh I just like how he took all
the fear out of the Manson Family just
like there's a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
hippies who killed a bunch of their
creative talented people in the prime of
their lives
and then the other people who weren't in
show business down the street that he
didn't very soon become thank you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip and you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this cuz this
is alarming